more now we're joined by Amber Phillips
staff writer for The Washington Post
amber good morning good morning so we
heard the president say you know in
effect why didn't President Obama do
more about the Russian hacking written
regards to the election these latest
reports kind of bolster his claim
absolutely the president has been saying
for a while now you know as the Russian
investigation under him intensifies well
why aren't we talking about you know
Hillary Clinton's emails or why the
Democratic National Committee didn't
cooperate with the FBI kind of
suggesting this stuff since the
Washington Post report came out actually
one day before he's just outright saying
it he's outright saying oh you think I'm
too nice to Russia look at the Obama
administration it's kind of a I know
what I am but what are you argument here
are we going to see any change maybe in
the scope of the Russian investigation
because of what the washing Washington
Post revealed it's certainly possible
and I say that because the special
counsel that the Department of Justice
appointed has wide latitude to
investigate whatever he wants under the
umbrella of Russia Congress in addition
to that is running their parallel
investigations they can look at whatever
they want to they don't have
prosecutorial powers but they can look
whatever they want and Republicans in
Congress just last week have already
kind of started looking back to the
Obama years they're going to be looking
at whether Obama's Attorney General
tried to like turn the dial in favor for
Hillary Clinton and the FBI's email
investigation this week amber we also
heard the president effectively in the
guessing game over
tapes yeah saying he didn't have any
tapes and he hadn't made any tapes is
does that put this all to rest
I wouldn't bet on it ah two reasons uh
when every time he talks about oh there
are no tapes he leaves himself wiggle
room where he says maybe there are tapes
somewhere which is kind of a fanciful
argument to say maybe someone else was
recording the President of the United
States in the Oval Office but he left
himself that argument secondly you could
argue that that one tweet threatening
James Comey about tapes has led to this
obstruction of justice charge because
the way James Comey tells it the fired
FBI director he woke up in the middle of
the night after
tweet he said I don't have tapes but I
had memos testified before Congress
about the memos and now here we are the
Special Counsel investigating the
President and president Trump even sort
of suggesting that maybe Comey may have
changed what he was going to say based
on that idea that there were tapes that
were out there right he's kind of giving
himself credit for that yeah we also saw
this week the Senate health care bill
come out and we have heard now that
there are five Republicans not on board
with the plan where do we stand with
this idea that we may see a vote next
week I think that Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell is determined to have a
vote next week if the nonpartisan
Congressional Budget crunchers the
Congressional Budget Office can sort of
review the bill and say how many people
could lose or gain health care how much
it will cost the federal government that
being said the vote could fail this is a
real possibility because the magic
number here is too right no Democrats
going to vote for this which means
Senate Republicans can only afford two
defections right now they have five
likely defections and they're not all
just conservative or just moderate yeah
you have an array of them like senator
Dean Heller we saw yesterday say he
can't support it the house didn't wait
for the Congressional Budget Office
number the Senate will the Senate has to
because they want to pass this in a way
that they can avoid any Senate
democratic filibuster which you know
they would try to filibuster over an
attempted rollback of Obamacare it's not
a repeal
so it's this budget rule called
reconciliation that essentially means
you have to know how much it's going to
affect the budget before you can vote on
it amber Phillips thanks so much for
being with us